the music industry has changed so much
in the last really two or three years I
wonder what the Grammys are for right
now what do they mean for businesses
whether it's a business of an artist a
label or I don't know Spotify it's a
it's actually a great question because
if you look over the last decades I mean
the Grammys has always been a the best
marketing event that the record label
business has ever had and you know after
the grammys there's usually a bump of a
2x2 an 8x on the number of weekly sales
you'd have on a CD or an album and
you're going to see that in the spotify
charts this week but i don't know what
it's going to do for the revenue of the
music business right after the grammys
it's a great question well we actually
spotify just let us know about what
happened with beck and that that record
recording album i'm still stuck with
sigma 20th century nouns but spotify
just needed that Beck's the Becks
worldwide streaming shut up five hundred
and twenty four percent overnight after
winning that record of the Year thing
Kanye West probably helping a lot by
dissing that win what it you know so
listen why don't we break it down go
through coupling so foreign artists and
artists perhaps whose music was the
least listened to all day he was a
surprise winner sort of except that he
was nominated so he kind of narrowed the
field a little bit but for someone who
had the least listen to record Spotify
predicted Beyonce would win cuz she had
the most downloads that ain't how the
Grammys work no not at all in fact I
think Beck was 5th out of 5 on the
Spotify charts simply because the
Grammys are an industry event so there's
a very small committee of people that
actually curate the the people who are
nominated in the first place and then
the voters themselves are members of the
National Academy of Recording Arts and
Sciences so you know it really comes
down to the demographic and tastes of
the members not really what's being
streamed the only thing that streaming
really has an effect on is just like any
other promotional vehicle like radio or
MTV or now VEVO it's just in its in the
amount of exposure that it gets and how
many times a person of the Academy might
listening to it not necessarily the
general public though I would say that
you know it is the music business so
people in the music business are
thinking what's going to be able to sell
more records so if it is a popular title
and they think they can sell more well I
say records two albums see these digital
download streams you know just to get
more exposure is important no recordings
I think that'll work you know I think
that also that that one of the
interesting things here is that the
digital services have made it much
harder for things in terms of musical
discovery finding what music listen to
they've also made it a lot faster to get
the music itself you know if you get a
Spotify subscription you haven't heard
Beck's record BAM you've got it if you
don't know who beckons knees i standing
in the stage performing of the Grammys
you turn on shazam you identify the
artist because you didn't hear a little
cool j introduce him and then all of a
sudden you're listening to this new
music and so I wonder if the importance
of something like the Grammys in terms
of music discovery because music
discovery so much harder now because
people aren't listening the radio that
the Grammys becomes those tentpole
events become much more important I
actually completely agree with you I
think that just some of the duet some of
the really incredible combinations the
great thing about the Grammys is it's
not about speeches it's about
performances so I think you'll see
people thinking about the Grammys going
forward is more of a discovery event as
well as unknown artists and artists
combinations that you wouldn't have
heard about yeah so I wonder if then
there are more events that have to
happen there or sort of the great
important apps might be things like
Shazam that help people find the music
that they like or find similar music
that they like absolutely in fact I mean
Shazam Spotify songs there's so many
different really interesting playlists
companies that are coming out right now
that are helping with discovery though I
will say that there's this inflection
point between discovery and exposure and
then cannibalism and that's the you're
seeing that with Taylor Swift right now
where you're in the rarefied air of
being really important being discovered
is great through these services but then
when you start to just purely consume
only through these services the artists
themselves are going to find themselves
you know hurting their
helping business and finally I wonder
about the impact of social media where
the artists that have big followings on
Instagram or Twitter end up getting both
more airtime more you know fancy clothes
from the swanky designers and and all
that because social media is leading to
their sort of popularity on a lot of
other platforms other than just
recording music yeah I mean look at
Meghan Trainor she was up you know for
awards this this year and she's
incredible on social media I think
social media in general is becoming this
direct to consumer opportunity for
artists and you know I've gettin a lot
of them I've had two major artists like
two of the top artists come to me in the
last year just to try to figure out what
do I do now that I have this direct to
consumer following how do I make money
off of it because now you see Beyonce
putting out midnight records you see a
lot of money being made between touring
and building a brand that it's it's not
necessarily happening through the sale
of music that social media is playing an
incredible part of it and it's going to
reshape the way we make money or at
least artists make money in the future